aujourd'hui aussi événements dans touche
pas à mon poste et oui c'est sa première
avec nous on est très heureux
d'accueillir catherine la banque qui est
avec moi
la classe l'élégance les chéris
attention vous allez essayer chacun
votre tour
si vous arrivez 1 si vous arrivez alors
je vais faire un odieux celui qui
arriverait pic le salaire de quelqu'un
qu'il veut ici autour de moins que lui
et encore moi inclus j'ai pas de
salaires donc comme ça vous l'avez dans
le cul l'onu attention on y va ça qu'à
votre tour vous désigner quelqu'un je
pense je pense un salaire aujourd'hui à
dcb live
excusez moi alors donné oui non mais tu
décroches et à merck escalade tout à
l'heure il n'est menacé ce que tu
faisais des les salaires deux battus
alors sang royal veut que tu prennes un
salaire de moto alors j'ai craqué
vous travaillez pour belime aujourd'hui
je vous jure que c'est vrai on s'est
fait un peu on pourrait vous pourrez
peut-être le récupérer allez gilbert
montagne on y va l'asie gilbert non à
gâteaux pour fiat
gilbert attention que ça touche pas levé
tiré dessus mais ce n'était pas possible
sans rigoler il le fait exprès
catherine alesi 4 il adore tu fais une
très belle entrée dans l'émission à
c'est son premier jeu c'est très très
belle entrée de catherine laborde merci
matthieu delormeau aggravant gâteries
alors on y va essayer de récupérer votre
salaire
vous récupérez salaires et vous en super
c'est simple le vôtre tant pis c'est ce
qu'il a choisi alors il est con comme
moi non je pense une benjamin castaldi
je les suivais pas longtemps oui va
aller ou non leur a dit de manière aisée
attention j'ai c'est si j'y arrive je
prends le salaire de tout le monde c'est
normal annoncé normal
non non pas j'annule tout il aurait dû
tout 4ème vous un oui pas pauvres
ce que je propose sans rigoler voilà et
je le dis franchement à part catherine
son premier jour ce que j'ai gagné
monsieur nouveau boss comprennent tous
les salaires et qu'on les offres à une
association
voilà aujourd'hui non mais c'est vrai
voilà je vous le dis pour envoyer des
enfants en vacances c'est bientôt les
vacances on apprend le salaire de tout
le monde aujourd'hui même le bien ou
livrent à du très bien sûr le merde et
on envoie des vacances pas à part
catherine parce que c'est son premier
jour je peux pas lui faire ça d'accord
mais chérie c'est fait et ben voilà
[Applaudissements]